el 11 de julio de 2021 miles de cubanos
salieron a las calles para manifestarse
contra el gobierno en pocas horas las
protestas se expandieron a toda la isla
las redes sociales jugaron un papel
fundamental en la movilización las
críticas rescatadas los apagones de
Electricidad las horas de fila en las
tiendas la escasez de alimentos y
medicamentos y la subida exponencial de
casos de Kobe 19 todo esto ha grabado
por el embargo económico que padece al
país el pueblo no está alterado porque
no hay comida porque hay problemas y
para todo es una situación y para todo
es una cosa el presidente Miguel Díaz
canel acusó a Estados Unidos de fomentar
las revueltas incluso llamó a Los
Seguidores del sistema imperante a salir
las calles para enfrentar los disturbios
y por eso también aquí estamos
convocando
a todos los revolucionarios del país
a todos los comunistas a que salgan a
las calles en cualquiera de los lugares
donde se van a producir estas
provocaciones las manifestaciones
dejaron un muerto duraron poco tiempo ya
que fueron fuertemente reprimidas
después de eso también a toda forma de
activismo la vigilancia y la persecución
fue peor la forma del espacio Cívico se
cerró aún más ellos intentan evadir
cualquier cualquier mínimo
forma de protesta pública porque saben
que lo más mínimo puede detonar otro 11
de Julio en el año que siguió las
autoridades cubanas condenaron a cientos
de personas apenas de cárcel porque
cargos que iban desde desorden público
hace edición